rishi sunak is the former investment
bank analyst now running the uk's
treasury and widely regarded as a likely
successor to the current prime minister
boris johnson when the uk went into
covet lockdown in 2020 sunac's
government-backed furlough scheme
subsidize the salaries of more than 11
million workers at a cost of 95 billion
dollars
now he says it's time to start balancing
the books
i have to be blunt with you our recovery
comes with a cost
our national debt is almost a hundred
percent of gdp
so we need to fix our public finances so
this week low income families will stop
receiving a temporary twenty pounds or
27 us dollars a week uplift to a social
benefit called universal credit and
taxes are going up too it's going to be
a very tough winter for some
my great worry is that we're going to
have lots more people pushed into the
arms of loan sharks forced to use food
banks and actually that's unnecessary
you know the government could just
continue with the 20 pound a week uplift
into the winter into the spring and
summer next year and that would just
alleviate a huge amount of financial
pressure on low income families across
the country including here in greater
manchester on monday the army began
helping to deliver fuel to petrol
filling stations a very visible sign of
the uk's chronic shortage of truck
drivers the situation which has caused
petrol pumps to run dry and also seen
empty shelves in supermarkets
many economists are warning that the
united kingdom faces a cost of living
crisis in the coming months as energy
prices go up and the government claws
back some of the benefits it paid out
during the pandemic what's not clear is
whether the chancellor's proposed ways
of mitigating that damage are enough in
deprived areas such as salford
proposals include a scheme called
kickstart to help young low-income
workers and incentives for companies to
take on apprentices
in his salford workshop mike cleary says
he's just about getting by
we're ticking over that's the main thing
uh we could be we could do a lot better
what we are doing
but again without proper training
without
the bully being pumped into
apprenticeship scheme
then it's welcome to a stand still
next month rishi sunak delivers a formal
budget which will detail the
government's financial plans but the
indications are that for many in the uk
things are going to get worse before
they might get better
paul brennan al jazeera manchester